Sweden's government has declared itself
the first feminist government in the
world yes really according to the
government website a feminist government
ensures that a gender equality
perspective is brought into policymaking
on a broad front both nationally and
internationally
women and men must have the same power
to shape society and their own lives and
quote know when that feminist government
visited Iran one might expect that the
empowered women in this empowered
government would be empowered enough to
avoid donning the hijab the Islamic
female head covering nope
meeting with Iranian president Hassan
rouhani the women universally put on
head scarves apparently feminism only
demonstrates his strength when dealing
with Western men who are basically
willing to work with feminists not when
dealing with patriarchal societies
intent on the subjugation and repression
of women as UN watch reports quote trade
minister and Lind and other female
members walked before Iranian president
rouhani on Saturday wearing hijabs
shadows and long coats in deference to
Iran's oppressive and unjust modesty
laws which make the hijab compulsory
such a show of submission follows hard
on Deputy Prime Minister Isabella Levin
explaining to the world that Donald
Trump represents an a threat to female
rights this is kind of indicative of the
focus of Western feminists with the vast
majority of sexism wiped off the map in
the West women in the United States
comprise a majority of college students
and graduate students and earn more than
men in 147 out of 150 highly populated
cities if they have no kids instead of
turning internationally the feminist
Left has found new windmills to pursue
forcing other people to pay for women's
child-rearing fighting for the ability
to kill babies in the womb at any stage
of pregnancy that means abandoning women
living in actual patriarchal autocracies
so why won't Western feminists fight for
women living under tyranny because that
would mean empowering men in their own
countries to fight radical Islam and
that would undermine the pacifistic view
of Western civilization that too many
feminists think is a prereq for female
equality a muscular defense of Western
civilization makes feminists
uncomfortable they see that as merely
the flip side of the Islamist coin which
is why the only time they bother ripping
radical Islam is when they're saying
Donald Trump is a member of the Taliban
the result is that women who are
actually oppressed have no feminist
allies in the West and that means
they're on their own as those same
feminists kowtow to their would-be
oppressors i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
all righty so we are going to get to SNL
we're gonna save the Grammys for
tomorrow I think there's a lot going on
at the Grammys and I want to do
deconstructing culture we'll do a
full-scale deconstruction of the Grammys
tomorrow on the show but we're gonna
focus on si now we're going to talk
about Steven Miller's bombshell debut on
the sunday shows and what that means for
the Trump administration we're going to
talk about the left going nuts but first
we have to say thank you to our
advertisers over at blue apron so if you
are in need of a fresh meal and
something and you want to cook you want
it you want to make the meal yourself
you want to make sure that it's healthy
you wanna make sure that it's fresh blue
apron is the way to go so the way that
it works is that you go to blue apron
and they have a bunch of recipes from
which you can choose they send you a new
recipe every night if you want and it's
like 10 bucks per meal per person they
send you all the ingredients in the mail
so instead of you going to the to the
grocery store and stocking up on
ingredient half which will go rotten in
your fridge over the course of the next
three months blue apron sends you
already made all of the all of the
various ingredients that are gonna go
into the dish they send you the recipe
as well and then you can make all of the
meals in under 45 minutes so it's a
great deal $10 a person and it's become
a huge thing an outlet like everybody in
LA is using blue apron and they have a
freshness guarantee they promise every
ingredients in the delivery is ready to
cook when it arrives or they will make
it right and you can choose from a new
variety of recipes every single week or
you can let their culinary team surprise
you and they don't repeat recipes within
a year so you're never gonna get bored
so my wife has started looking at the
blue apron recipes to copy them for for
kosher audiences specifically because
the fact is that you know we have the
same meal like every Tuesday and it's
really horrifying so blue apron makes
sure that doesn't happen anymore and
blue apron can do that for you as well
some of their upcoming meals sound
fantastic it's like ooh da noodle soup
with miso and soft-boiled eggs crispy
barramundi with keynote with quinoa and
roasted carrot salad and then some pork
dishes that sound good if you're into
pork that's your thing
they have cashew chicken stir-fry with
tango man's ribs and jasmine rice I mean
these are really top-notch recipes and
you're gonna want to check them out it's
blue aprons comm slash Shapiro blue
apron comm slash Shapiro and when you do
that again you're letting them know that
we sent you which is it helps us out so
that they know that they ought to
continue advertising with us and it also
means that they know that
that you're listening to the show which
is great so blue apron calm slash up
here and yet the first three meals free
which is really the best part of the
deal so the first three meals you get
free with free shipping if you go to
blue apron comm slash Shapiro sits like
a $30 value so that's that's pretty
solid value just for using our promo
code okay so lots to get to today but we
want to start with SNL so this is the
first week in like five six eight a
thousand weeks Donald Trump has not
tweeted about Saturday Night Live on
Saturday night and there's a reason for
that and that's because Saturday Night
Live has basically turned into the annoy
Donald Trump show instead of them
actually doing funny things they've
decided it's more important to do things
that irritate Donald Trump and there's
always been this aspect SNL I mean going
all the way back to the 1970s when they
did Chevy Chase's Gerald Ford he bumped
his head on things and he was like a
clumsy oaf even though Gerald Ford was
actually the most athletic president we
ever had who's an all-american
linebacker at University of Michigan and
football Gerald Ford but they portrayed
him as a bumbling oaf and it worked the
the SNL has always been sort of gadfly
against Republican presidents they don't
care about Democrat presidents they
never made fun of Bill Clinton
particularly much as a general Hammond
but it was kind of weak Obama they never
even touched I mean Obama was just a
worship choir for eight years
well now Trump is president and that
means that they are going to dedicate
all of their strength and all of their
minimal skill toward targeting president
Trump and here's the thing there's so
much about the fact that Donald Trump is
president that is actually funny okay
it's like there's a lot that's funny
about this Donald Trump is a funny funny
human everybody is sort of funny but
Trump it takes it to a new level like
his tweets are crazy sometimes and
whenever he talks he talks to this rich
self-assurance even if he doesn't know
what he's talking about and he says
things that are outrageous and he has a
sense of humor like there's there's a
lot about Donald Trump that you could
make fun of and a lot of the people who
surround him are funny so Sean Spicer is
his press secretary is a funny guy
inherently because he's sort of this
insecure guy who's playing macho on TV
and that's why when melissa mccarthy
last week did her impression of Sean
Spicer it was actually really funny but
now SNL has decided that they're going
to go full-scale
annoy Trump so we're not gonna try to be
funny so much as just annoy Donald Trump
a lot so it begins Sno on Saturday night
with Leslie Jones who Leslie Jones has
become sort of this
this Bugaboo of the right ever since
Milo went to war with her on on Twitter
over her role in Ghostbusters a terrible
film and so there are a lot of people
saying wouldn't it be funny to tweak
Donald Trump by having Leslie Jones play
Donald Trump on TV this this this black
woman who's very much to the left
wouldn't it be really funny
so they constructed a skit just for
Leslie Jones to play Donald Trump and
again I guess the idea here was just to
take off Trump's that he tweet about it
and it doesn't really work very well
it's whole skit this this one's actually
not one of the worst ones this one's
actually okay but it's it but it's again
designed to take off Trump right there
and people were saying this beforehand
the whole reason for casting Leslie
Jones took off Trump and then they
brought Melissa McCarthy back I guess
under the theory that once you beat a
dead horse to death you can continue
beating it until it actually decays into
just bone so they brought Melissa
McCarthy back to do Sean Spicer again
and again it's okay but like really
aren't you bored with this all right
like why don't you bring this back three
weeks from now you got to bring it back
every single week now they're repeating
in there beating the dead horse and it's
it's not again out of these the end of
the world no but the entire show is
dedicated to drum this is only the
second of four sketches they were
dedicated Donald Trump here's Alec
Baldwin doing a People's Court parody of
Donald Trump again it's like all they
have to do and they don't really care
whether people think it's funny or not
they really only care whether Donald
Trump gets annoyed enough to tweet about
it so I guess it's there and that they
failed because you didn't tweet about it
this is I've really enough I'm not a fan
of Alec Baldwin's Donald Trump and I
think the writing for is is really weak
so this was only the third of four and
finally we get to the one that's
actually really bad the one that was
actually really really bad was Kelly on
Conway so they they've been ripping on
Kelly and Conway for a while which is
fine with me I'm not a big Kelly on
Conway fan but the way that they ripped
on her flat on Saturday night really was
truly egregious what they did is they
suggested that CNN wouldn't have her on
because she was dishonest because there
was that story last week about this and
when they did the skit instead of just
doing it like a horror sketch like she's
haunting the lake she's haunting Jake
Tapper at CNN they tried to sexualize it
and it really is kind of insulting and
gross here's what it looked like again
this is actually this is the worst of it
so they've gone so far off the rails and
now that Kelly I encounter one who's
married it has four children they're
trying to play her as though the reason
that she's trying to get on TV is
because of sex or something and now
she's trying to hit up Jake Tapper by
the way also married with two children
if they did this is somebody on the Left
everybody would rightly cry sexism right
it is I mean I'm sorry this is sexist
it's sexist to take a woman who is on TV
you may not agree with her you may think
she's terrible you may think she lies a
lot but the idea that she is that she
has some sort of sex fiend who's you
know going over to people's apartments
and sexing it up with random dudes on
the news he's really pretty gross and
this just demonstrates how far the left
is willing to go in order to pillory the
right and what they're doing is they're
actually undermining their own
credibility there are plenty of
credibility issues with the Trump team
and we're gonna get to some of those in
a little bit but the left deep desire to
override anything remotely resembling
truth in favor of just the most absurd
material possible all that's really
doing is it's off-putting half the
United States and yeah SNL's ratings are
good right now but they're not doing
themselves any favors when they go so
far over the top they're actually
insulting to the members of the Trump
administration not just kind of gentle
mockery or even harsh mockery or even or
even kind of cutting mockery but turning
Kellyanne Conway into a sex fiend or
suggesting that Donald Trump is
legitimately too stupid to do anything
there's there are certain wines that you
cross at a certain point that or not
yeah I'm not saying anybody should be
shut down but I am saying that it's
counterproductive to what they're trying
to do and it's not funny so that
Kellyanne Conway thing is actually so
far past the line it's not even funny
like you watched that and I can see the
humor in the Leslie Jones thing because
half of it is is about how she's an
incompetent actress but the Kellyanne
Conway thing is so far over the top that
it really is is insulting to I think
women generally actually we have to take
a short break here and say thank you to
our friends over at C so so my wife and
I have been watching a lot of material
over at sea so it's three ninety-nine a
month and you get as much comedy as you
want they have all the all the stands up
comedy that you could possibly want they
have all of the old episodes of SNL when
SNL was actually good they have all of
the old British office they have back
logs of comedy and all commercial-free
and they have a bunch of new shows as
well some of which are really funny too
they all sort of all like Monty Python
they have 30 rock and Parks and Rec so
if comedy is your thing if you need a
little bit of relaxation then you go out
and go to see SOCOM three ninety-nine a
month and right now if you go to see
SOCOM if you use promo code
check out you get one month for free so
you can try it out see if you like it
see so calm and use the promo code Ben
at checkout you get one month for free
no ads you can stream as much as you
want and it's got all of the stand-up as
well it's got louis c.k who's really
funny I'm big Louie CK fan got late in
all the late-night shows it has so it's
a one-stop-shop for comedy see so calm
and then use that promo code then okay
final note on this it's not just
restricted to SNL of course the left has
lost its mind over Trump and what
they're doing again is undermining their
own credibility so Andrew Sullivan who
has been irrelevant for at least five
years here he used to be over the
Atlantic he used to be considered
somewhat of a conservative who's sort of
a Pearl Rock war conservative Andrew
Sullivan in 2008 he lost his mind and he
started talking about how trigger Palin
Sarah Palin's son was actually Bristol
Palin's son
they had this trig birther conspiracy
and then Obama invited him to the White
House is some sort of brilliant
commentator and now he is saying that
Donald Trump is crazy
now some politicians fear bin lion fact
almost all of them due to some extent
but they always do it in a way that pays
some sort of deference to reality and
what we've discovered is that in the
last three weeks
this president rather like he did on the
campaign trail simply insists that black
is white the things that we can see with
our own eyes like the size of his
inauguration crowd and not exactly what
we're seeing and he's able to command
his underlings to actually go out there
and also say things that are empirically
untrue this is not about Paul as the guy
critiquing Donald Trump now I mean
they're really dragging these corpses
out of the woodwork to criticize Donald
Trump the guy who thinks that Trigg
Palin was not actually Sarah Palin's kid
is actually Bristol Palin's get Rob
Reider
like now they're dragging the director
hasn't done anything good since Princess
Bride out of the out of the walls in
order to criticize from he calls Trump a
cancer seeing all over the country with
protests and I've been in many of them
is nothing like what I went through when
I in the 60s when I protested against
the Vietnam War
this is everyone it's not just people
worried about being killed in Vietnam
this is everyone and so we
looking at a cancerous presidency that
we cannot allow to spread and so so many
things come at us that's pretty radical
rhetoric again cancerous presidents who
we cannot allow to spread so what he
supposed to kill it
he's calling for assassination what's
the what's the implication here again
all of this does is really help Donald
Trump okay we're gonna have to take a
break over at Facebook and YouTube gonna
watch the resting over to Daily wire com
become a subscriber for $8 a month you
can subscribe annually and if you
subscribe annually then you got a free
copy of the Arroyo which is a great film
by a-- by jeremy boring about the border
crisis it's about a fictional it's
fictional film and it's about this this
rancher who lives on the border and drug
cartels are using his land as a
thoroughfare and what he does about it
really good film daily wire calm to
become a subscriber and join us we are
the most popular conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
you